[Música]
el presidente de el salvador nadie
busque el anuncio que buscará la
reelección en los comicios de 2024 el
mandatario se ampara en una resolución
del año pasado de la corte suprema de
justicia que cambió un criterio en un
artículo de la constitución
inmigrantes en situación irregular en
eeuu llegaron el jueves a la residencia
de la vicepresidenta kamala harris ya
una isla frecuentada por altas figuras
demócratas es la más reciente maniobra
de los estados republicanos para poner
presión sobre los demócratas a menos de
dos meses de las elecciones de medio
término la casa blanca habla de peones
políticos
la vicepresidenta de argentina cristina
fernández de kirchner rompió el silencio
tras el intento de asesinato del que fue
víctima a principios de septiembre dijo
estar viva gracias a dios y a la virgen
al tiempo que llamó a erradicar la
violencia y los discursos de odio los
sospechosos del ataque fueron procesados
por intento de homicidio agravando
momento de actualizar las noticias en la
pantalla de france 24 mi nombre es juan
para pieles y esas son las noticias más
destacadas del continente americano
comenzamos en el salvador porque en la
noche del jueves y en el marco del día
de la independencia el presidente de
nadie busque el anuncio que buscará la
reelección en 2024
bukele en el poder desde 2019 y siete de
la potestad de presentarse a un nuevo
período amparado en un cambio de
criterio hecho por los magistrados de
las salas de lo constitucional que
fueron electos por aliados de buque en
el congreso en un proceso que fue muy
criticado el mandatario defendió los
alcances de su guerra contra las
pandillas que según dijo está a punto de
ganar escuchamos algo que le ahora que
empezamos a estar bien hay algunos y
quiero recalcar algunos
de la comunidad internacional que
empiezan a condenar las mismas acciones
por la que estamos bien no las
decisiones previas las acciones por las
que estamos bien critican la guerra
contra las pandillas critican el régimen
decepción critican la captura de
pandilleros como si quisiera que
volviéramos a estar mal el único camino
que tiene el salvador es este
que ya también lo probamos no es una
promesa de campaña ya lo probamos y nos
está funcionando es por eso que luego de
compensarlo con esposa gabriela y con mi
familia
anunció al pueblo salvadoreño que he
sido correr como candidato a la
presidencia
[Aplausos]
previamente en medio de las
conmemoraciones por los 201 años de
independencia del país este jueves se
registraron protestas en las calles de
el salvador en rechazo al gobierno de
boc l se trata de unas movilizaciones en
contra del régimen de excepción que rige
el país desde finales de marzo y que
esta semana se extendió por sexta
ocasión el ejecutivo defiende esta
medida como una herramienta para
combatir el auge de las pandillas
mientras que sus detractores denuncian
que bajo esta norma se han detenido unas
52 mil personas sin ningún tipo de orden
judicial bajo la sospecha de pertenecer
a alguna organización delictiva
escuchamos algunas voces de los que
integraron la protesta
[Música]
derecho a salir a marchar
a las calles
necesaria
pero
no queremos que nos sigan violentando no
queremos que nos sigan acosando el
pueblo no quiere más retroceso
queremos independencia en los poderes no
queremos la reelección el papá francisco
reconoció este jueves que hay diálogos
con el gobierno de nicaragua fueron unas
declaraciones que el pontífice entregó
en su vuelo de regreso al vaticano desde
kazajistán
estoy nicaragua en noticias sociales
sobre nicaragua las noticias son claras
para todos hay un diálogo continuo
hablamos con el gobierno hay diálogo eso
no quiere decir que aprobemos cualquier
cosa que haga el gobierno o que
desaprobamos todo el diálogo y lo
necesitamos para resolver varios temas
en este momento hay varios problemas
el papá también se refirió a las
misioneras de la orden de la madre
teresa de calcuta expulsadas de
nicaragua la frontera con costa rica en
julio
previamente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal en san jose sinde regidor
quien nos habló de la importancia del
papel de la iglesia en nicaragua
es importante verlo desde dos ámbitos
desde lo religioso en nicaragua se han
registrado las detenciones arbitrarias
de sacerdotes e inclusive del obispo
monseñor rolando álvarez esto ha
ocurrido en los últimos meses pero
además desde las organizaciones sin
fines de lucro como lo es la asociación
misioneras de la caridad más de 1.700
organizaciones han sido canceladas por
el gobierno en los últimos cuatro años
el gobierno justifica que han incumplido
unas leyes el mismo gobierno pasó hace
un par de años y que naciones unidas
considera que van en contra de la
libertad de asociación
estas organizaciones sin fines de lucro
han dicho que además es parte de un
intento de control total por parte del
gobierno y parte de su deriva
autoritaria las misioneras de la caridad
fueron canceladas y fueron precisamente
expulsadas como ya lo decía si habrá que
ver si el gobierno cambia de parecer y
de esta particular o en general en su
postura en contra de las organizaciones
de sociedades civiles
la política de algunos estados
republicanos en estados unidos de enviar
inmigrantes en situación irregular a
otros estados bajo control demócrata dio
un giro este jueves el gobernador de la
florida brondi sanz disfrutó dos aviones
que llegaron a la isla vacacional de
martha's vineyard en massachusetts y
otra parte el gobernador de texas envió
dos buses hasta las afueras de la
residencia de la vicepresidenta cámara
jarvis en washington dc a casablanca
denuncia esta iniciativa el informe de
alva santana
la crisis migratoria interna sigue en
eeuu el jueves un nuevo grupo de
emigrantes llegó de texas a washington
del autobús y esta vez con un destino
muy concreto la casa de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris
por esos seguros gente vivo
creo que es un verdadero desastre creo
que es horrible cómo está utilizando la
gente como peones
y es que texas ya ha transportado en
autobús a más de 7000 migrantes a
washington dice la nueva york desde
abril algo que ha supuesto un gasto de
al menos 13 millones de dólares su
objetivo hace recaer la responsabilidad
de los migrantes sobre estados
gobernados por demócratas una acción que
usa a personas con fines políticos
versión de the way we need hay una forma
legal de hacer esto y de gestionar a los
inmigrantes que los gobernadores
republicanos prefieran en este proceso y
utilicen a los inmigrantes como peones
políticos es vergonzoso imprudente y
simplemente incorrecto
una acción a la que otros gobernadores
republicanos como ron de santis en
florida se han sumado mandando a un
grupo de inmigrantes a la isla de
martha's vineyard en avión una región
rica en la que suelen veranear
demócratas relevantes como el ex
presidente barack obama
nuestro mensaje para ellos es no somos
un estado santuario es mejor poder ir a
una jurisdicción santuario y sip
ayudaremos a facilitar ese transporte
para que puedan ir a pastos más verdes
una situación que también ha violentado
a los migrantes esperando
para conseguir un trabajo a menos de dos
meses de las elecciones del 8 de
noviembre en florida y texas muchos
tachan este movimiento como el último
intento de los republicanos para ganar
votos
un veterano jurista de nueva york es el
perito independiente designado por una
jueza federal para que sirva como una
tercera parte en la revisión de los
documentos incautados el ex presidente
de eeuu downtown en su residencia
vacacional de florida se trata de
raymond de wii quien fue designado por
la jueza federal del distrito sur de
florida aylín canon es una decisión que
va en contra del pedido del departamento
de justicia que había solicitado de la
suspensión de un fallo que había
prohibido al fbi avanzar con la
investigación de un centenar de
documentos clasificados encontrados en
esa residencia de malagón la jueza cano
fue designada por el propio donald trump
vamos a argentina porque la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner habló por primera vez desde el
intento de homicidio en su contra el
primero de septiembre durante un
encuentro con sacerdotes hizo un llamado
a erradicar los discursos de odio de
otra parte una jueza dictó prisión
preventiva para los principales
sospechosos de haber intentado atentar
contra la funcionaria mi primera
actividad pública por así decirlo o
fuera
de un despacho fuera con ustedes yo
siento que estoy viva por dios y por la
vida realmente el papá francisco me
llamó bien tempranito al otro día
de s
de ser ese jueves el viernes tempranito
me llamo estuvimos hablando por teléfono
y me dijo algo así como qué
los actos de odio los actos de odio y de
violencia
siempre son precedidos por palabras y
por verbos de odio y de violencia
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
que desde nuestra pantalla y también la
información continua france 24 punto com
[Música]